I want to start by saying
congratulations on the movie I thought
you all did such a great job but I'm
here to get into the most important
stuff about the making of the movie
which is apparently rap battles on set
yeah
so I'm very curious can you talk about
where these rap battles came from and
were you involved was it just you - my
spectrum of talents but we did rap for
her constantly yeah her yeah it started
in the hotel room we'd be like in
between commercial breaks of raw we
would start loud play like Biggie beats
and then he's very musical very rhythmic
guy so it started off with just like
NSYNC dancing and stuff like that and
then hand motions came in and then he
started rapping and I love to rap and
then it became like a bonding thing and
then it translated to RAF days where we
just eat up time like that but yeah a
lot of hotel room we were in hotel all
together I mean we were together all the
time so yeah it would be like ways the
past time rock-paper-scissors so okay I
also heard about group hugs can we can
we talk about group hugs love people
have been working so hard and doing like
everything about what they have been
love to do and that it's they dare been
during our breaker job he's talked about
big group hugs like there we have our
our bar group hugs but he's talking
about like crew hugs I never had that
before 50 people hugging like that I've
never heard I've never been part of a
hug that's 50 people me neither he was
started off he's like a galvanized ER
for the two of you I'm very curious this
is being made by first-time feature film
directors and I'm curious and they put
together this unbelievable cast what was
it about the script and the story that
said I need to be a part of this I don't
know I read it and I watched the proof
of concept and I knew that these two
were gonna make it and I'd
was like I have to be there I need to do
that hmm I just had to it's a really
beautiful story I've never read anything
like it and I I don't know there's not
like one specific reason it was just so
important to me to make this film yeah I
would say the same thing I got my
stories dense but they had a long stash
or story is I knew they would be here
I knew they'd be able to play with them
and mad respect just from the
proof-of-concept respect for her as an
actress and a doll okay we can play this
would be fun and then yeah originally
there was another actor named Ben Foster
on the role and then Ben foster wife had
a baby and me and him have a history and
then he was like hey man you know one
for one and sort of like gave me the job
kinda yeah that called me out the blue I
was getting ready to go to Finland and
he called me on the phone and say you
really got to be a part of this so then
that's how it happened for me it was
this Ben Foster call hearing about the
cat seeing the proof of concept before I
ever read the script I was in got it I'm
very curious if you were disappointed
you were not part of the watermelon
helmet scene yeah uh yeah I do feel that
I thought about that last night I was
like [ __ ] and then I thought about how I
could just do that in my own life
probably in this month coming my way
that's something that I'll be doing
maybe by myself
or not we'll see what happens that
that's definitely a shareable moment on
if you'll be like long lens paparazzi
pictures of me somewhere with it
watermelon helmet on no why
I completely for the two of you was that
scene scripted or where did that come
from because I was laughing as I watched
that no a lot of more stuff there we
have these truth units where me and him
would just sort of float off and mess
around with each other and we had a
watermelon and we were just actually
supposed to be like having a picnic and
we had a pocket knife and then it turned
into helmets and then turning a fight
and then yeah their beauty is zach is
like wherever you float you're gonna win
you know better than the script quite
often even though script was fired but
when every time we would float off the
script we'd find like
really incredible moments like beautiful
stuff anytime you'd like really zero in
on him and you know it doesn't take much
dude it doesn't take much but ya know
not scripted I got I already got to stop
I'm just gonna say again congratulations
thought you guys did such a fantastic
job
good luck with everything